hey this is Pete peppers and I was going
to make a quick video today to explain
the answer to a question that a lot of
players ask about Diamond digger and
it's about a lot of times when people
are playing early in the game they never
run into this and then when it happens
they are confused as why they still have
moves left but the game stops so in this
case you can see that we need to collect
toys and we see these exclamation points
all right and what that's telling me is
that in this particular room I'm playing
level 477 which is a frustrating one and
what it's telling me is that I have to
collect more toys before I open the exit
and I said and specifically in this case
I need to collect them all I know that
from playing it before sometimes there's
a certain number of toys you have to
collect or so this can happen in toys
levels or in fireflies levels you know
levels where you have to collect things
other than point and in some of them
there'll be a certain number you have to
get before the ! will go away and in
others you'll have to collect all of
them and it just depends on how many
there are how many toys or how many
fireflies there are and if there's
extras so here you can see that if I set
up the red I'm going to open up this one
right here and the door is going to open
and it's going to not work so
so I'll get this pop up here that says
you missed too many toys so in the in
the in the future what I need to do is
make sure that I don't open the exit so
the water goes out before the toys pop
up so I'm going to pause the level or
pause the video and start again and I'll
show you how that changes whatever I do
it the right way alright so I played a
couple moves and now i have i have
already cleared out one of the tanks and
now i have the other this one's ready to
go and this one needs two matches so
that's an ideal situation on this level
so now i collected the ten toys from
that those two boxes and now when I open
this I'll collect those toys and it
allowed me to move to the next room
without any problems so like I said it
can happen in fireflies or toys levels
anything where you have to collect a
certain number and it comes up
throughout the game I mean it will
happen very early on some levels and
then come up later so just look for that
! it'll be above the toys it could be
above individual tiles with toys or the
fireflies and you'll also see it up here
by your total so I hope that clears up
why you sometimes can't move on and
Diamond digger to the next room and you
lose lives it doesn't matter how many
lives you have or anything else because
there's a set number of toys of
fireflies that are coming up so you
won't be able to complete the level goal
in this case 34 out of 34 toys if you
don't get enough in the room that you're
in at that time so I hope this helps
leave a comment if you have any
questions and please like this video and
share it if you found it helpful so
other people will find it and we'll be
making more how to play videos soon so
subscribe to our channel thanks